Male: We finished the last video with
the scenario where company A wants
to buy company B,
but they're not going to do it with cash,
they're going to do it with their shares.
They issue a press release saying
that company A intends
to acquire company B
for $60 million in A's shares.
They want to give a price that's a premium
to company B's current market cap
so that it's compelling,
so that the shareholders of
company B want to do this.
They're like, wow, that's a 20% premium
to our current market cap,
so we're willing to do it.
Since this is a share transaction,
company B shareholders won't
exactly get $60 million.
What's going to happen
is company A's going
to issue 2 million in new shares.
Those 2 million new shares, in theory,
could be worth $30 a share.
Maybe they could sell
them in the open market
at $30 a share so that they
would be worth $60 million.
Instead of trying to raise the cash
and then giving the cash to company B,
they're just going to
take those shares directly
and exchange them for all
of the shares of company B,
essentially acquiring the
company with all of those shares.
Every shareholder of company
B, for every share they have,
they'll get 2 shares of company A.
If at the time of closing, company A's
stock price goes from $30 to $35 a share,
then the transaction price would,
if you think about the
market value of those shares
that company B's shareholders
are going to get,
the market price would
actually be $70 million.
If the market price of company A goes down
to $25 a share, then
they're only going to get
$50 million worth of shares.
What I want to think
about in this situation
is what should happen to company B's stock
before the transaction
closes, if we assume
that everyone thinks the
transaction is going to happen?
Let me draw a stock chart here.
This is price.
This is time right over here.
Let me draw company B's stock price first.
Let's say right now it is
trading at $50 a share.
That is company B.
Right now company A's
trading at $30 a share.
Notice even though that their share price
is lower than company B's share price,
they have a much larger market cap
because they have many, many more shares.
They actually are a larger company
so it doesn't sound crazy for
them to acquire company B.
Now, this is the day that
everything was announced.
Let's just assume that everyone thinks
the transaction will happen.
For every share of B a B shareholder has,
they will get 2 shares of company A.
If company A does this, what should happen
to company B's stock price if everyone
is 100% sure the
transaction's going to happen?
Every share of B is going to be converted
into 2 shares of A.
After this point in time, if you're sure
the transaction's going to happen,
each of these B shares
should be worth 2 A shares,
so they should trade exactly at twice
the value of the A shares.
Right when the transaction was announced,
if everyone assumes it's going to occur,
B shares should immediately
jump up to $60 a share,
and then they should always
trade at double of A's shares.
If they trade at less
than double of A's shares,
then, instead of buying A shares, people
would rather buy B
shares, or they could buy
half of B shares.
Or let's say there was
someone who was going
to buy 2 of A shares, instead they'll say,
"Hey, look, B shares are
trading for less than
"2 of A shares, but
they're going to be worth
"2 of A shares in the future
because of this merger,
"so I'm just going to
buy B shares instead."
There's no reason, if everyone assumes
the transaction's happening, that before
the transaction closes that B shouldn't
trade at exactly twice
the stock price of A.